from its ingenious sound design to a
limited use of Gore to Jack Nicholson's
iconic portrayal of Jack Torrance The
Shining left a permanent mark on horror
here's how the shining changed horror
movies forever and ever and ever one of
the ways the shining stands out from the
horror crowd is through Stanley
Kubrick's hyper-realistic lens this
terrifying tale is not told in the
familiar shadowy environment most horror
movies prior to 1980 had used to bump up
the scare factor in fact the majority of
the film takes place in broad daylight
at Kubrick's signature style to the mix
and the result is one beautiful looking
movie with common tropes out-of-the-way
Kubrick's signature sense of cinematic
framing and lighting helps to place the
audience firmly into the mood and world
of the Overlook Hotel the story becomes
accessible in a way that many horror
movies don't as supernatural as things
become this is still a human story
Kubrick nails this point home by
presenting each frame with a heightened
sense of realism that pushes
psychological boundaries in a way that's
almost unnoticeable everything seems
fine slow tonight in disrupting this
genre formula not only keeps viewers on
their toes it also results in a
compelling story that never stops being
creepy
The Shining made it clear that it was
okay to bring your monster into the
light not only does Stanley Kubrick
focus on the get under your skin moments
found throughout the shining but he also
commits to creeping out audiences
through an unexpected use of sound in
silence as we've been reminded with the
box-office success of a quiet place
silence can be a major tool in
amplifying a sense of dread and danger
there are moments throughout the shining
following Danny's tricycle through the
overlooks winding hallways comes to mind
where the audience only hears the sounds
of the wheels regularly transitioning
from the hard floor to the soft carpet
it's not much to watch but as the camera
follows Danny
our perspective is minimized and becomes
childlike add to that the unexpected
sound cues of the movie score and the
results are quite unnerving the result
finds the audience no longer receiving
warnings that the visual horrors are
right around the corner and with those
guidelines thrown out of whack a steady
stream of dread and anxiety comes into
play we've already mentioned the film's
color palette and uncharacteristic use
of light and realism to add to the
terror but the shining doesn't stop
there what Stanley Kubrick pulled off is
akin to the other classics in his
filmography you made a well produced
well acted well written film for decades
the horror genre has fought tooth and
nail to climb its way out of the jokey
b-movie recesses that have remained its
home
[Music]
at its heart the shining is the tale of
a family fractured as its patriarch
descends into madness it's a story that
be easy enough to tell under low budget
circumstances but Kubrick was a
perfectionist he elevated the genre
through cutting-edge methods and
high-quality production these standards
not only left an impact on horror movies
they forever changed cinema throughout
the shining Kubrick focused more on the
personal demons Jack Torrance and his
son Danny we're dealing with yes there
are still spirits haunting the hotel but
their appearance here coincides with
Jack's own troubled past the ghost
stories just to mask the deeper more
human horse using horror as an allegory
for a real-life issue as as old as the
genre itself but with the shining
Kubrick crafted a legitimately
terrifying film that works on all the
potential levels if you're scared of
Hotel ghosts don't watch The Shining and
if a family man giving in to his
addiction in violent ways makes your
knickers quake don't watch The Shining
and while prior horror movies like
Rosemary's Baby and Night of the Living
Dead were steeped in allegory the
Shining's cultural impact influenced
modern horror filmmakers to give their
movies depth that goes beyond jump
scares one of the biggest horror movies
in recent years get out explores its
themes in similar ways and director
Jordan Peele hasn't been quiet about
drawing from The Shining 4 that he went
so far as to admit that he even quote
totally ganked the opening title credit
hedge maze out here in the same vein the
which director Robert Eggers told / film
when I watch the which sometimes I'm a
little disgusted by how much of my film
flagrantly reeks of The Shining at the
same time I will admit that if it wasn't
for that I don't think the film would be
working for people at all before the
shining hit theaters a popular trope
explored in horror was that of the evil
child from The Twilight Zone episode
it's a good life - films like Village of
the Damned and the omen
the creepy child motif had been a strong
one in genre entertainment it still is
but the shining represented the
beginning of a transition suddenly
movies started paying less attention to
the young Antichrist wreaking havoc at
home and focused more on telling
empowered tales of survival and
redemption through the innocent
perspective of the children themselves
in putting Danny Torrance in a position
of power with the help of dick hallorann
showing him the how to shine the boy
became the beacon of hope throughout the
entire film
you've got the shinning you mean shine
English you want to get sued as the 80s
progressed and films like a Nightmare on
Elm Street it and The Goonies arrived
the trend of empowering children gaining
the upper hand against the evil adults
of the world grew exponentially
Kubrick's The Shining flipped the
proverbial script turning this adult
child dynamic on its head check out one
of our newest videos right here plus
even more looper videos about your
favorite movies are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one
you
[Music]